let's jump to the story from NBC News
some supporters of a far-right convoy
headed to the Texas border are calling
for civil war we love NBC news they are
crackpot far- leftists but uh sure a
group that referred to itself as Gods
Army said it was planning three peaceful
assemblies on Saturday the Convoy has
attracted only a small number so far
well like 12 people I think they say
it's a trucker Convoy of self-described
Patriots headed toward the US border
with Mexico they've expressed violent
rhetoric before ah you see they don't
give examples they don't give examples
they never give it's fine it's like when
they say that the they're they have
specific tweets that are bad and they
never actually include the Tweets in the
article do not this is why I agree with
James Lindsay James James Lindsay said
do not go down there oh yeah I agree I
think you go to Texas stay away from the
border let Greg Abbott do his job we've
already learned today from a field
reporter who's actually been there that
what Greg Abbott has set up has
massively worked you were saying before
it it's bedum and then once the National
Guard comes in now it's 4 to six like
which is an insane contrast single
digits from
10,000 I think was 10,000 the whole
border though or was so it's in certain
diff they break it up into sectors uh
when I was down there they were breaking
records every single month so you had
thousands coming through it wasn't like
10,000 all at once you never see any
Crossings like that but you do see
thousands per day sometimes and as soon
as the National Guard of Texas takes
over it has mostly the problem if people
show up and get in the way you're
getting in the way of the guys winning
it's like no don't do that don't do that
especially because it looks like NBC is
trying to Prime normies to expect
violence and calls for civil war so do
not give them an opportunity to false
flag and I'll almost likely be down
there covering whatever this turns into
uh but I don't really see it going very
far I mean I saw a Fox News hit the
other day where they said 700,000
Vehicles were on their way which I don't
know where they came up with that number
contct people in the Convoy it isn't
happening that's not how big they are
yeah you have a few thousand people
heading down but there's also three
different end points so they're going to
be split up between three different
endpoints in different sectors of the
border so I'm not expecting you know a
huge crowd there but articles like this
is it's basically just priming people
and prepping people for what would be a
false flag like what are you possibly
going to do going down to the border to
actually help National Guard or to help
the good guys win in this it was very
different than the tur Convoy where
they're basically locking down all
around Canadian Parliament and saying
we're going to make your life so
difficult because you have made our life
so difficult I know I don't really see
the same symbolic thing I understand
wanting to show your support obviously
wanting to do something I I I like the
idea of called action but ultimately
anyone I know who knows about this has
started being like feds feds everywhere
yep and and a lot of people think it's
going to be j6 all over again I feel
like that about anything where there's
any amount of protest now right because
it's not a matter of who goes it's a
matter of who controls the media
narrative or around what happens you
know but I don't think the media media
narrative matters as much as people
think I I I I I'm well beyond this like
we just saw digital media implode over
the past few weeks and it's been in
freef Fall for the past couple years one
of the worst days ever they got to call
it like bloody Thursday or something how
many layoffs there were this week yeah
Taylor Loren's video of her complaining
about all of it I mean they're laying
people off during election season you
know election writers as well which is
insane but I have a problem with you
know people not attending like I
understand protest I understand the
point of them obviously they're not
hyper effective especially after January
6 but everybody has essentially been
neutered after January 6th and I was
there on January 6 so I understand the
ramifications I'm not saying don't
protest don't organize don't get
together don't have assemblies I'm
saying don't go up against CBP on
federal jurisdiction during a conflict
like especially when border patrol has
essentially sided with a National Guard
in this situation I think the protest
was planned before the Shelby Park stuff
happened but now that this is actually
going on it does lead to potential
problems or conflict and I don't
care in Arizona have you been at the
Arizona border a few times not not as
much as CP facilitating illegal
immigration everywhere everywhere so
when they come out and they're like no
you know we agree with Texas and then
they they go now keep the human
smuggling running in Arizona I'm like I
don't care that you you get no free
passes yeah they've realized they've
lost in Texas but they still got New
Mexico they got Arizona they got
California so they're they're probably
looking at it like Hey we're a bunch of
human Smugglers Taxas is going up
against us if we go to war with them it
could screw the whole operation up let's
call it a loss and then shift all the
cartel operations to these states so we
can keep getting our Kickbacks or
whatever it is they're doing well the
reality is is they haven't even lost in
Texas at this point just in the Shelby
Park and Eagle Pass sector which is
where most migrant I mean illegal
migrants do come through because 15
miles upwards you're still having you
know illegal immigrants cross this area
so it's still happening you're just not
seeing these massive groups but you are
still allowing they're still allowing
people to be processed and there are
rumors that you know any immigrants that
are being you know basically detained by
National Guard or essentially being
handed off to CBP there are some videos
out there so it could still just be you
know it could just be for looks which
would be a shame but I don't think it is
that in this case um but they need to do
this for all of Texas the entirety of
the Texas border if they're actually
serious about stopping illegal
immigration completely I think when we
see the actions of a lot of people on
the right I shouldn't I shouldn't say
the right you know but there are people
who claim to be anti-establishment
who in two seconds jumped ship and went
full full on establishment at moment's
notice and I wonder what would happen if
a civil war actually broke out and I
genuinely believe if in Texas something
kicked off between the feds first people
should understand this when we had Eric
Prince on the culture War show shout out
tenant media Friday mornings 10 a.m. he
said I asked him like do you do you see
in the United States similar things to
these countries you've been in and he
said the one thing I can tell you is
that everybody I know who's been in
these countries they said it happened
overnight one day you went to bed
everything was fine you woke up the
internet's out electricity is out you
have no idea what's going on and that's
true if you're in the conflict region
what is also true is that most places
it's the it'll be it'll it'll be it'll
be nothing what'll happen you're in New
York right you'll go down to your Bodega
to get a uh I don't know maybe you want
to get a turkey with American cheese on
a Kaiser oh man is that what they eat
out there I I used to so I would I would
get whenever I would go to the bodegas
yeah I'd be like turkey white American
yellow American Mayo Kaiser heat up so
good I love me my my bodegas but you're
going to be there you're going to see
the clerk who you know your neighbor and
you're going to be like and he's going
to be like 13 more dead down at Eagle
Pass the fighting's getting crazy down
there and you'll go wow that's crazy
anyway uh uh you see the parade at the
park we're going to go check out you're
going to be there later all right see
you there MH when I was in uh I went to
Ukraine in 2016 and or 2017 and this is
ongoing fighting happening in the Dan
bass region at the time but it was
limited
skirmishes nobody in Kiev had said
anything like it's whatever and it was
funny because when if when the fighting
first kicked off people were saying
Civil War but then Donald Trump becomes
president the fighting starts simmering
down and I go there my friends like we
don't say Civil War it's just
separatists fighting and I'm like
fascinating and it was completely out of
sight out of mind for everybody there
went to a sushi restaurant went to a uh
I don't know what you to call it fast
casual with buffet style and got cabbage
and beef it was delicious had fun well I
think the US is a very unique place in
the aspect of it's probably going to
happen just like you're saying it's
happening is you know you'll have
different regions of the US that aren't
affected by it at all it's just news to
them and a lot of people they won't even
hear about the news at all they won't
even understand that anything is going
on and then finally you will have
something crack that does affect the
rest of the country but the way that the
US is set up and the way that our
economy and everything else is set up in
this country is it's not just going to I
don't think it's just going to be an
overnight thing black out completely you
know all across the United States and it
very well could be Eric Prince's a
genius I mean he knows his stuff for
sure but the way that we're set up here
in the US is very unique compared to all
these other regions that experience
massive attacks like this if you're in
these border regions where fighting
breaks out yeah you're you're going to
wake up with no electricity yep I mean
the the federal government's going to be
like we need to cut off their energy we
need to cut off their Communications
you're going to wake up and have no
internet your phone's not going to work
and there's going to be
military Insurrection act declared there
will be either Texas or federal military
securing the area saying everything's
under control go back inside your house
and you're not going to know who's who
uh imagine you're in Texas near Shelby
Park Eagle Pass you're in the city or
whatever and a and an APC pulls up and
guys in military uniforms jump out the
average person can't tell the difference
between National Guard and and and Army
and this guy just they they pull up they
Park the trucks out they're standing
guard you get out of your house there's
something going on like a everything's
cool man uh you know name's Jim which is
in security because there's been some
conflict stuff going on but you got
nothing to worry about have a nice day
which who is it which faction is you
won't even know M it's like that uh the
trailer for civil war yeah what kind of
American are you they don't know who he
is well the most unrealistic thing about
that is a Texas California Alliance that
no that's totally realistic the the
movie has Texas and California as their
own countries not as two countries
working to the it is not one country
with two states Texas and California
both wanting Independence would align
militaristically to defend their
sovereignty they wouldn't be operating
under the same governance so that makes
it makes a lot of sense flying like one
flag though with two stars okay yeah but
there's like a NATO flag yeah here
here's here's here's my point when I was
saying earlier you've got Florida a lot
of prominent conservative voices in
Florida if Civil War or some kind of hot
separatist action or whatever breaks out
in Texas not saying it will who knows
I guarantee you will get these
right-wing uh
personalities immediately saying I'm on
the side of Joe
Biden and I'm not talking about right
now it's easy to be like Texas is in the
right but if it comes to the point where
Texas is in active full full-on bullets
flying conflict and federal agents are
returning fire and then the Insurrection
Act is declared and then Joe Biden
declar he says Insurrection Texas blah
blah blah
it's going to be real interesting
because the question will be will
Florida say this is overreach and abuse
of power by the federal government this
is an in escalation what will state say
and more importantly for those content
creators with a national audience and
National ties Which side will they find
themselves on that's when you really put
people to the test the question is who
do you think's going to win for some
people it's who do they want to win so
there will be some media personalities
and I think
the higher the higher I don't want to
name anybody and put anybody on the spot
but there are some prominent
personalities that are streaming on you
know you YouTube and Rumble that I fully
imagine would be absolutely on the moral
position whether it is morally right or
wrong whatever anyone does they're gonna
they're going to stick to their guns
there's a handful of people I would
imagine outright would just be like hey
guys I'm with Joe Biden on this one
it'll be interesting to see well the
people that don't have convictions and
can hold themselves to their morals
they're going to be the side you know
siding with the Federal government
essentially siding with the big man and
that's really all that it comes down to
you side with the side that's in
Rebellion or he inates the Insurrection
act you are now putting a Target on
yourself and not a lot of people
especially commentators are actually
willing to go that far they don't want
documents like that I'll give you an
example Claire Leman do you remember her
off the top of my head I don't think
whatever happened to that lady do you
guys remember CLA Leman no she was uh
intellectual dark web she runs quillette
I believe she probably still does she
was of the uh you know the intellectual
dark web people were like post liberal
academics thinkers and and media
personalities that had been challenging
woke Orthodoxy and the establishment
narratives and right and so she's
running quillette and quette was his
publication that was like basically
disaffected liberal classically Liber
classically liberal and then Co happened
and Australia set up actual internment
camps were forcefully relocating
indigenous people I remember that story
and she came out in full defense of it
why
she's living under the boot of an
authoritarian regime and so she's
thinking to herself I will go to prison
and be locked up in a camp if I speak
out against them so the only thing I can
do is be on their side and I think you
could see the cognitive disson and the
shattering of her mind because she knew
if I start calling out Howard Springs we
have that t-shirt like come vation
Howard Springs there were there's one
story where three indigenous kids in a
small community in the middle of nowhere
they came took them under suspicion of
covid contact brought them to an
internment camp and locked them up and
said you can't leave they threw like
blankets over the razor wire jumped the
fence and escaped and they were hunted
down they were trying to arrest him I'm
like yeah totally voluntary covid you
know camp and she's like they're not
concentration camps I'm like well
they're literally driving up in Vans
taking indigenous people and people from
their homes bringing them to camps and
locking them up they're concentrating
them now okay fine Fair Point you you
you think the illusion to World War II
is too strong in tournament camps yeah
she this this is my point there's going
to be a lot of people who will flip on a
dime and they would have been the most
Libertarian people in the world but the
moment they realize hey look man I live
in DC I I live I live just north of DC
in Maryland I'm going to get arrested in
two seconds if I speak up it's going to
be interesting to see who does this
prove that as well a lot how many people
kind of fell under the regime as soon as
things started getting called that way
like you said she immediately Falls in
line because of the way things are going
and I think that would continue I think
it's fair to point out too don't not
everybody agrees on everything okay here
we are right now saying to the people
who are going down Texas we do not want
violence we need Trump to win in the
event something actually kicked off hot
I am going to maintain that position to
hope for stability so that Donald Trump
can still take the presidency that being
said I don't know and I'm not going to
say anything as to what happens here
other than we don't want it to happen
you do not want Civil War I don't think
the average American gets it to be fair
I think the average person who watches a
show like this gets it a little bit
better and all of the military veterans
get it
100% it is your the world you knew is
gone you will continue shopping and
eating food and cooking but man you ever
see a rabbit eating grass outside just a
little ball of stress the whole time you
never know when you're about to get
snatched up by some bird of prey or some
owl or who knows what and so you're
hiding all day every day it is not going
to be fun you know you never know when
someone's for no reason going to going
to attack you and maybe even
accidentally it's just not going to be
it's not going to be as chill and
comfortable is this the issue Trump runs
on immigration immigration and economy
he already is he's already run got 2016
they're saying like what is his biggest
loss right now is female voters right
like does the does the vote on migrant
crisis affect does that really push the
female voters in his demograph like his
I think immigration is becoming a very
unifying issue for conservative or even
moderate people because the effects are
so far-reaching and they can see them
all the time uh the thing is with the
Convoy to the Border there are people
who want to be involved they want to be
on the ground whatever else I would say
that Abbott has been preparing to be in
this position for a long time and it's
better to let him work and to be
supportive in a different way H it's the
same thing with Trump I mean people will
criticize Trump saying he didn't do
enough when he was in office to achieve
you know whatever with with immigration
but we because he was the president we
have advanced this conversation and it's
become even more mainstream under a
Democratic president they couldn't deny
what was going on thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8:00 pm and become a member
over at timcast.net